everyone this is d blonde rope with
Collider and I am here with Tim Miller I
can stare loving me a long uncomfortable
interview before we go get started the
only reason we get to be at South by
Southwest is because we have awesome
sponsors I want to give a huge thank you
to supper sweet sorrow tequila
hint water it's delicious right and
what's funny is this was the I won't
even bore people with that but the point
is I want to give a huge thank you to
everyone that made it possible for us to
be here so sincere thank you it helps
with hangovers wait are you saying it
went out drinking last night I didn't
right I was gonna say okay so there's a
lot that I want to talk to you about and
I've seen six shorts of this 18 of 6 6
of 18 and the one thing that I can say
about it is that it's really hard to
explain cool you're either cool or
you're not it's like one of those things
in the shorts that I saw are all really
cool how the f did you pull this off I I
wouldn't say that I'm cool but it does
it does remind me of my dad in college
he wrote me a series of letters called
words to live by and one of the one of
the letters was if you're trying to be
cool it will prevent you from ever
actually being cool because truly cool
people don't have to try which I've
floated that rule my entire life because
I try and be cool the how do we know I
don't well I don't know you haven't seen
all 18 so let's see what you think I'm
confident that it's gonna be good I know
I feel I feel like they're all
interesting I can only speak for me
right and and David has his favorites I
have my favorites but I I really love
all the stories or they wouldn't have
been in there I mean we had a huge
[ __ ] list of potential stories and
these were the ones that we thought oh
well this is gonna work but a lot of it
is like a wine
pairing or maybe a beer pairing in this
case cuz wants to highbrow but you know
it's what goes good with what else right
you don't want too many of the same
thing
sure well so you have 18 shorts when I
saw it I saw six and what was
interesting about the order that I saw
them in was it was like sigh hard sci-fi
something completely different something
completely there was a but the way you
played them was almost like an album
pairing like watching it you know like
when you're listening to an album so
when people are watching the 18 at home
which is available in a few days is
there an order that you've set well
there is and but you can go in it's it's
Netflix is really trying some different
things on on the service where you can
go in where you choose like you can look
at all the stories and choose where to
go in and then it'll take you back up
and I'll start playing through the order
that we think works best but but really
the the we think works best is is really
just my guess at what I would want to
see and and that's kind of based on no
solid theory other than I some of them
are really heavy so you want to give
people a little light palate cleanser
after that and there's different lengths
so I want to play with that and then I
want to mix up the styles because
there's a there's a ton of ways to mix
it in fact there was a huge discussion
with Netflix about you know how to
change it up and show it differently to
people based on what they may what their
interest may be which is one of the best
things about Netflix when you were
working with the the directors the I'm
curious was there a mandate for running
time where you said to people it needs
to be at least four minutes and no more
than 12 we had a rough idea because
because we developed the each one to a
script level before we handed it off to
directors which doesn't mean that they
couldn't change it or expand it or
whatever I just wanted to know that I
was giving people a solid story before
they even started that way at least you
have a baseline
you know you can always go well it kind
of worked there or all right well if you
want to expand this that's fine but at
least you have something that you you're
pretty certain is working and then we
had the the story length which kind of
based
what the story needed to be and then
there was budget but on in almost all
cases all these companies that we chose
really saw this as an opportunity to do
something great and they put a lot of
work into it and almost everybody did
more time than we were paying them to do
because they just what I just want to do
great they just want to make it great
but the other thing is that what's cool
about the the work that I saw is that it
allows people you know to be inventive
and to put themselves up there or to
also as you said it's like a calling
card for your studio totally you know
what I mean this is like a great ad that
a lot of people are gonna see you to
demonstrate well this is the animation
we can do for you if you want to give us
some cash oh yeah and I mean and not
just that it's just that all these
people especially the smaller studios
and the boutiques which is mostly who
did these when you go with the exception
of Sony when you go there you're usually
a client it's coming in with a mandate
and we're really lucky at blur with our
clients that they come to us because
they they want to give us some creative
freedom but nobody gets this kind of
creative freedom usually where we say
here's you I mean a lot of them we said
here's three three different stories
that we think your studio would be good
for who do you who do you which one do
you like which one would you enjoy doing
most you don't get that kind of chance
usually so everybody not only saw it as
an opportunity to put their studio
forward but they were genuinely excited
about the just being let off the leash
you know one of the things I found while
watching the shorts that I saw was I can
imagine that there's gonna be fans a lot
of people are gonna watch this and
there's gonna be certain people that are
like oh my god that's one my favorite
one I need more in that world are you
like already mentally ready or you know
because everyone now is so obsessed with
like universes and expanding storylines
that some people are gonna call for or
ask for more stories set in one of those
worlds or a few of those worlds um we're
totally up for that I mean whether it
turned into something larger that's
another nice thing about Netflix you
know you've got movies excuse me yeah
movies you've got
longer-form regular series you could do
but also we could always tell another
one in that world you know we had we've
already done we had one sucker of souls
which wasn't in our list by this author
named Kirsten cross and and we really
loved it so I just asked her if she'd
write another one with those characters
because I'd liked that one we found that
one it just so happens but I said I know
I know there's some challenges to
writing another one in that universe I
won't tell you why but I but I really
like the characters so she just wrote
another one or just in case we get
season 2 you yeah we're there did
everyone I'm trying to work out this
budget question but we're all the
budgets even or were you allowed to like
spend more in certain ones that dictated
needing more money we controlled the
budget but we had a budget was more
dictated by the kind of animation it was
versus and running length versus who was
doing it and why right so if if it's
photo real animation and that was the
goal and that was the company that was
doing that the studio then that budget
was different than 2d animation because
2d animation doesn't cost as much so it
was really driven by that and and then
and there were some companies where it
was not a case of here bid this story
and tell us what you think it costs it
is here's the budget here's the
suggested running length and here's the
budget can you do it for that if you
can't thank you anyway but Lily you got
to partner up you've been friends with
David Fincher for a long time talk a
little bit friends now right
friendly you know right talk a little
bit about collaborating with him on this
because I know this is like animation is
this kind of thing it's been something
he's been interested in for a little
while so um what was it like and how did
you guys come together on this well we
we've been wanting to do an animated
anthology for for 10 years at least and
trying to do that you know we tried to
do a heavy metal film for a long time I
live always loved anthology that which
is why we're kind of doing this
story because I've read so many short
stories over the year I had a ready
library so when I went and I met David I
don't know 15 years ago or so he I
showed him a bunch of projects that I
was interested in and and one of them
was an anthology and he's like [ __ ] we
should do that because we can experiment
we can try working with different
artists we can different styles he
always liked it he was going to he was
going to do one I hope he does one maybe
next time but it he just loves animation
and and and you know what he really
loves artists he loves the creative
endeavor which is kind of why we were
friends he came to the studio and he saw
that we had you know this big warehouse
full of people and they're all
relatively enjoying their job and trying
to do creative [ __ ] and he just likes
that vibe talked a little bit about the
you have a lot of different directors
artists working on this thing who was
the most difficult to procure in terms
of getting on board this project and why
all right you knew nobody was difficult
it was really it was like everyone was
like oh I'm in oh yeah we have to talk
anybody into it right because I haven't
seen obviously all of them so I'm not
sure if they you know what I mean I'm
not sure if there was one person or no
no no it was no everybody we we didn't
go
we didn't go hat in hand to anyone and
say hey please join us they they just we
just said hey we're doing this do you
want to join most people said yeah
seems to happen in movies Karen Sony in
Deadpool who was dopinder the cab driver
he was the hardest actor to land he fit
in the whole movie like to talk into
doing it because he thought it would
interfere with TV his TV career to do
this movie and we had to we really I
called him he said no and then Ryan
called him he said no Simon call him he
said no call them again and that's so
funny
mostly because I mean since that movie
I've seen him in a bunch of things it's
obvious a lot of casting people saw him
and I think he had a good career before
that but but
it was he's such a nice guy it was just
his he thought maybe being in movies
would end his his other endeavors and
and and and that's why he was reluctant
but he gave in eventually um one of the
things about Netflix is that they
announce things and then it's basically
on the service right after they announce
how a lot of people aren't going to
realize how long have you been working
on the animation and these stories
because I think this has been going on
behind the scenes for a while it's been
two and a half years I think since they
said yes actually was right after
Deadpool David called me literally the
weekend that Deadpool came out and said
okay now we're gonna make another push
to do this and and then a week after
that he said and we're gonna do it in
Netflix that's crazy yeah it was crazy
it's long it's been a while it takes a
lot longer than everybody thinks you
know usually by the time you make either
you're one of those people that make an
announcement early because you need the
reinforcement of your creative drive to
go out there and do it or you're one of
those people like David is who doesn't
want to talk about it mm-hmm what
actually what we've done the screening
I've done a screening series at Collider
for a number of years and one of the
coolest ones was the one I did with you
because we showed Deadpool like eight or
nine days before it came out before the
press had seen it in LA we did a
screening and the greatest thing about
that was it was before anyone at an
inkling of what this movie was going to
be so it was one of these screenings
were like we loved this movie this is
you know this is fantastic and then it
became a whole different beast
you know after it came out we had no
idea I mean we were sitting there
opening weekend going man I hope it I
hope it doesn't tank totally the
greatest the greatest story and I think
a lot of people don't realize is when we
did that screening and I remember
talking to Ken Berg being like you know
so what's like the dream number and they
were like you know 20 to 40 million and
we're gonna be super happy oh yeah and
it's just it was I mean I've never been
a part of you know that kind of
ridiculousness yeah it was crazy yeah I
definitely have to talk about working
with Netflix everyone has been setting
up projects there and obviously listen I
love them and I love what they're
putting out are you guys talking about
doing other things
with Netflix like what's going on green
well you know Davey's got a long
relationship with them so he's talking
all the time
I really had a super experience I mean
this the this series has nobody to blame
but us if it doesn't work because
Netflix was like look you guys do what
you want clearly you have a vision for
what this show can be and they didn't
they didn't tell us we couldn't do
anything they didn't tell us we should
do anything they just said go make it
great so I would love to work with them
again I I hope we get a season two what
was gonna say so the the dream is it
comes out on the 15th
I would imagine within a week they
generally know if people are clicking on
this thing or not so so the idea is if
it's successful you guys totally want to
do more well you're gonna think I'm
being disingenuous here but I'm not but
yeah I really want we might not know
that oh they won't tell you anything
well it's none that they won't tell you
it's just that sometimes these things
take a little while to that you've you
have Netflix I'm sure so you go on
there's so much [ __ ] to watch that and I
don't mean [ __ ] like bad stuff I just
mean there's so much stuff and so
sometimes it takes a while to find that
I you know I I loved Ozark I still
haven't watched season two because I
just haven't had time so we're in the
same page on yeah I loved the first
season yeah having that time yeah also
my wife and daughter watched it without
me and so I now I have to watch it on my
own in that and that's really trouble
but but I mean you know sometimes it
takes it takes two it's got to build a
little word of mouth and momentum which
I think this is kind of built for
word-of-mouth more than than anything
else even though Netflix is doing a big
push behind it and showing it here and
getting David Knight down here it's
great and if you happen to live in LA
you'll see a lot of billboards and but
then we also did influencer screenings
in San Francisco and Vancouver in New
York and London and London one when does
the London one happen oh it happened
last night or why didn't what happened
but by the way net net Netflix people
are a right off camera I want right ah
yeah
the London screening hasn't happened yet
but by the time you're watching this it
will have happened yes yeah so they're
all influencers so which it's kind of
cool to hear no no listen I I got to see
it in LA at a thing and it was listen
there's nothing like seeing it I wish I
will say that I saw it on on a movie
screen I wish that more people could see
it like that because it looks so good on
a big screen you know the world's you
guys have created yeah David David
Fincher's we somebody said the same
thing last night it's like oh my god it
sounds so great in a movie theater so
much better than watching it in home and
David said not in my house but David
also I don't even want to probably get a
pretty I would imagine that David has
yeah I'm sure he has a pretty good set
up every director I've spoken to when
I've seen them like out and about has
like these super fancy really nice like
Leica cameras or you know like I'm sure
David has been treated very well by
people who have like projectors or
screens or yes but just so you know I
don't have a nice setup so any product
plate no I'm just kidding yeah we have
very nice TV but it's not a if you have
blur yeah I've been a screening room I
was gonna say I've been I got I was
fortunate enough to go there and there
was a very nice screening room I believe
upstairs that I yes actually we have two
screening rooms now because the
Terminator post is there and yeah yeah
that's true that's fair enough I uh I
heard yet you are working on a different
movie now I read about that yeah just a
little thing a small little indie movie
right it it's it's a thing with you um
you have to go because you have a lot of
other press and then I think a plane no
no I can stay oh no it's sir
oh no no I will get in such I will get
in such trouble believe me there watch
those people as they circle there's
nobody there ladies and gentlemen no no
that was such Tim is totally
bullshitting there are no I'll get what
we call the hook and then when I ask for
a different Netflix thing in the TV you
know
the hook is when I get see when Adam was
standing there and he was going
this that means rap this [ __ ] up
and what happens is that I I was told
you have a hard out to catch a plane to
LA or is that not true they totally
making [ __ ] up
I'm staying here all week no I'm just
gonna be like I am why I'm doing more
pressing yeah no but listen we'll do a
follow-up because I have a what we call
other questions but listen I really mean
it sincerely I loved what I saw I cannot
wait to see the rest and let me know
when I can watch all three hours at blur
you liked the way I did that on camera
yeah on our big screen right on the big
scarf a expensive screen right exactly
seriously Congrats on all this thank you
so much for coming by HD
you